19 strikeouts in his first three starts
for toddler mcgill only two mets
have ever accumulated more over their
first three major league starts matt
harvey had 23 stephen mats at 20.
mcgill with 19 strikeouts and 14 in the
third innings to begin his big league
career 2-2 to newman and he puts him
away with the breaking ball
tyler mcgill strikes out kevin newman to
start the night
and he strikes him out on three pitches
high fastball gets hayes back-to-back
strikeouts for mcgill to start his night
3-2 coming
and he throws him the change-up and it's
popped up
mcneil and alonso and it's mcneil to
take charge of it and tyler mcgill has
himself a one two three opening inning
mets come to bat with no score there is
max kranik who will make his second
major league start in moments
a lot of excitement today and here's max
kranik's numbers brought to you by the
pennsylvania lottery in five innings
zero hits zero runs zero earned runs and
zero walks three strikeouts in five
perfect innings
in this young man's major league debut
there we go
limo strikes out looking
just like we were talking about he's
going to come after him with his
fastball and
fill that zone with strikes
trying to go up and in on memo right
there and he hit the spot
well nobody's perfect
uh you knew it was gonna happen at some
point if you put you up here long enough
you're gonna give up that first hit
they'll throw that ball away to
signify the first time you ever allowed
a baseballer
so now max cronic will do something he's
never done in the major leagues before
he will pitch from the stretch
and it brings up left hand hitting jeff
mcneal
mcneal rips one to right center field in
the gap that's a base and it'll go back
to the wall
lindor is in dom chugging at third he's
going to be waved home and the throw
gets away dom scores on a two run double
by jeff mcneil on the mets of an early
two-nothing lead
looks like a change-up that just stayed
middle not a pitch he goes to very often
and mcneil drives that thing in the
right center
really nice piece of hitting by jeff
six there it is 60th at bats is coming
back from the injured list and his first
extra base hit
[Applause]
dom with the wheels too scoring from
first i wasn't sure he was going to make
it but
throw got away from newman there well
oliva was throwing to second base for
some reason let's get the jump on max
kranick finds out that he's not in st
louis anymore so tyler mcgill in search
of his first big league win has been
given a couple of runs to work with
on the outside corner and mcgill gets
him looking at a fastball set him up
with two off speed pitches and mcgill
has his third strikeout really nice
pitcher i mean on the black that's
that's a beautiful pitch and as you said
set him up with the two off speed
pitches and then down and away with the
heater just to kind of give the hitter a
completely different look and froze him
one and two the count
now the pitch swung on and missed strike
three castro down on strikes the
fastball from mcgill gets him four
strikeouts for tylor mcgill and the
pirates have first and third and one out
and the best hitter on
the ball club brian reynolds coming up
and inspects that one to right that's an
rbi hit for brian reynolds
newman is in and the pirates have one on
the board it's two to one
they saw that fastball enough to get get
it timed up and was able to turn on one
get it into right field and bring home
kevin newman he hit it too hard for keep
ryan hayes to go first to third this
right here you see a good forcing
fastball grip
sawed enough times to get it timed up
down and then running back over the
middle of the plate and brian reynolds
put a nice swing on it drive us into
right right field started with that bun
hit by newman then hayes and now
reynolds
three straight hits reynolds with 51
runs bad at it now two up two down so
far max granick has handled the heart of
the men's lineup it
is the batter now he struck out his
first time one to one to alonso
and pete smacks one deep down the line
right toward the corner and
it's out of here
peter lonzo
a line drive home on
number 17 from peak that's three to one
new york what a bullet
i mean this is a case where alonso made
an adjustment
he's seen enough of these fastballs from
krannic to know
what he's trying to do with them where
he's trying to go
1-1 there
takes a shot gets a heater in and just
doesn't miss it i mean that is a
beautiful swing gets the head out on it
and keeps it fair
that was the thing of beauty gill could
use himself one easy inning hasn't had
one of those yet 20 pitches in the first
inning 24 in the second ending 22 in the
third inning only allowed the one run a
lot of work
2-2
and castro takes strike three call got
him with a change up
six strikeouts now for mcgill
and his 25 strikeouts in 17 and two
thirds innings mcgill now has 25
strikeouts
which is one shy of the mets franchise
record for first four starts of the
career
and mcgill one shy of that mark
he's ahead owen two on stallings
and now he's tied the mark
seven strikeouts today 26 through his
first four starts for tyler mcgill and
that'll be it for mcgill so another
short-ish outing for mcgill but another
successful one at least as he leaves
three and two thirds innings one run
loud well now stallings
[Music]
stallings gets into one out to left
home run for jacob stallings
that's how you earn your spots
the cheetah likes to jog
[Applause]
and now the pirates within a run here in
the sixth inning
home run number seven
jacob stalin's
102.7 miles per hour off the bat
what a great looking swing
knew that right on the crack right off
the crack of the bat
slider lugo was going to that hung and
stayed up in the strike zone and check
it stalin's crushed it
ball one strike on mckinney two out two
on mitts lead by run the pitch
mckinney slams one at the middle of
basic mckenna round third he'll come in
to score
and the mets get the insurance run they
were looking for billy mckinney with a
pinch hit single to drive in a run and
it's four to two new york big big rbi
for this team
give him a little extra cushion going
into the top of the seven edwin diaz on
to try and save it for new york oh tuna
reynolds
he struck him out and the ball game is
over
edwin diaz strikes out the side on ten
pitches in the seventh inning for his
19th save
peter lonzo hits a home run
jeff mcneal with a two-run double
and the mets split the doubleheader with
the pirates they've taken two of the
first three in this series as they win
this game four to two
[Music]